[Musique]
tu auras papers l'anc étaient ainsi
baptisé en référence à la légende de la
boîte de pandore censé contenir tous les
maux de l'humanité à l'intérieur 12
millions de documents collectés par 600
journalistes pour mettre au jour les
arrangements de centaines de
personnalités avec la fiscalité il
s'agit de personnalités parmi les plus
connues dans le monde des présidents des
premiers ministres des ministres le roi
de jordanie et plusieurs clients russes
et des personnes très proches de
vladimir poutine dont tony blair est
également cité pour l'achat d'un bien
immobilier à londres par le biais d'une
société étrangère dominique strauss kahn
aussi pour avoir fait transiter des
millions de dollars d'honoraires par une
structure marocaine exemptés d'impôts
quelqu'un que j'aimais beaucoup donc je
vais pas être très objectif qu'est-ce
que vous aimiez chez lui le côté battant
le côté battant le côté chaleureux ans
le visage de bernard tapie regarder
cette affiche et notamment au stade
pierre mauroy ou marseille affrontait
lille les supporters de l'om ont rendu
hommage bruyamment par des
applaudissements mais aussi par des
banderoles à celui qu'ils appelaient
ball boss il aimait se battre et il a
toujours aimé se battre et en fait c'est
plus beau combat restera celui contre la
maladie au pied de l homme très
intelligent et qu'il y avait un charisme
au sens étymologique c'est à dire une
force une grâce et bt aurait été
sensible à ça c'est l arme anti fn de
françois mitterrand il a bataillé contre
l'extrême droite jean marie le pen
c'est l arme anti fn me tiens il ya
entre jean marie le pen et bernard tapie
était un peu plus complexe que ce qui
paraissait sur les plateaux de
télévision
aujourd hui je crois que c'était une
notoriété certaine notoriété publique
voilà pourquoi il faut faire ce débat
parce que monsieur le pen monte pas
tellement dans son parti politique mais
ces idées se vendent bien c'est pour ça
que je veux qu'on parle des idées et pas
avec un gant de boxe c'est pas monsieur
le pen que je c'est ce qu'ont pris ces
idées et qui ont répondu saisine dans la
france a évidemment pour monsieur vers
ans qui a été biberonné aux jeunesses
socialistes
l'école du vice comme disait mitterrand
au ps un apparatchik puis il est monté
en grade comme ça a évidemment pour lui
ça lui par extraordinaire ça c'est sûr
ça c'est hors de son schéma mental tout
ça m'a fait sourire j'ai vu ça ça m'a
été réveillés ça m'a fait sourire c'est
la réécriture complète de ma biographie
si vous voulez ce que je suis on me dit
que j'étais chez les jeunesses
socialistes j'ai entendu qu'après
d'autres commenté en tant que j'étais un
ancien trotskiste monsieur virant qui
est la vérité incarner tout le monde le
sait qu'ils nous disaient qu'on n'avait
pas besoin de masques et puis après
qu'ils nous disaient que en fait on
avait besoin de masse qui nous disait
qu'on avait pas besoin de fermer les
frontières puis king disait après qu ont
fermé les frontières voyez monsieur
virant qui change d'avis comme de
chemise moi je soigne des malades dans
les hôpitaux en portant la blouse quand
certains faisait déjà du commentaire
politique sur les plateaux j'ai quitté
le parti socialiste en 2016 j'ai donc
passé quatre ans quant à savoir si
j'étais sûre d'elle trotskiste va
écouter sauf si dominique strauss kahn
et les trotskistes je me considère comme
lui plutôt au centre gauche eghezée
bourde de 2021 c'est jean marie le pen
des années 1980 serre qu'il retrouve
probablement dans eric zemmour une forme
de radicalité dans le dans le discours
de brutalité qui était peut-être celle
d'un certain nombre de propos qui ont
été tenus par par jean marie le pen il a
pas les solutions et vous savez pourquoi
c'est parce que en fait c'est un
excellent journaliste un excellent
polémiste mais il n'a jamais mis les
mains dans le cambouis donc il n'a pas
cette expérience d'élu local de
parlementaires de ministres de chiffres
qui ont résumé un peu la polémique le
vainqueur c'est sonny colbrelli chez les
hommes 30000 euros de primes et chez les
femmes
1535 pour la britannique a dit avec des
bananes
[Musique]